alors n'y couperez page sur les amours
on m'a offert une interview funérailles
nationales
c'était un petit peu difficile pour vous
puisque vous êtes mort donc vous êtes
mort comment à là bas je suis mort de
vieillesse
ouais vous l'avez trouvé comment le
discours de chirac à l'enterrement un
peu tremblotante
et quand l'équipe de la star academy a
chanté emmenez moi ça vous a ému
oui surtout que c'était la nouvelle
équipe les anciens n'étaient pas venus
j'avais des béquilles vous aimeriez
qu'on dise quoi de vous maintenant que
vous êtes mort charles aznavour pas
qu'on dise du bien
ouais ouais mais du bien bien pour
n'importe quoi qu'on me grandissent même
vous rendez vous avec vos ventes de
disques sont repartis c'est énorme
depuis que vous êtes mort nous avons vu
mes arrières petits-enfants et s
enrichir est ce qu'il ya des oeuvres
posthumes des trucs que vous avez jamais
publiées et en vivant et qui vont
ressortir maintenant comme les beatles
oui oui j'ai laissé ma voix sur des
bandes électroniques nouvelle et ils
ajouteront lors qu'est ce qu'ils
voudront ajouter de sucre dans un signal
est ce que vous savez qu'on va
rebaptiser rue aznavour la rue sarah
that
ah oui oui c'est de la noël qui est
toujours maire de paris qui était sarah
that je sais pas un violoneux sagnol à
un grand violoniste espagne je me suis
renseigné quand même derrière pas
simplement fikiel nom et de ses envies
pour le reste non je me suis renseigné
c'était quoi le dernier mot avant de
mourir charlesbourg
je reviendrai à bravo
alors charles aznavour quelques mails
les gens savent évidemment que vous
seriez là ce soir ils ont envoyé des
mails sur le site france2 qui s'inscrit
en bas de l'écran
vincent torres de toulouse dites-moi
chose à vous avez fait fogiel drucker en
aparté la star ac
il se vend pas votre album ou quoi non
on l'a fait pour que ça se vende ouais
mais c'est ça d'accord ni que guy baudet
de boulogne billancourt
est ce que vous pensez qu'avec la
canicule l'été dernier vous avez perdu
une grande partie de votre clientèle non
je le prends pas je l'avais déjà
renouvelé
jeune quand on fait ça bien steph l2 à
l'aise de strasbourg vous avez reçu en
1974 le prix de l'artiste pop le mieux
habillé
pourquoi ne pas vous être changé depuis
vous avez un peu stoppé
je dirais simplement que une fois qu'on
l'a dit plus d'importance à la fois un
mail d'hervé bottineau de bron savez
vous qu'il existe un remake d'un taxi
pour tobrouk qui s'appelle un taxi pour
que je te brutt
non il est imité chez flammarion
ah oui bon client très brillant
charlesbourg car les gens leur abandon
pour mener une séquence allons mener
quand vous voulez même si vous n'avez
pas de disque ou de livres à vendre
pourrait revenir buffin courage et pas
toujours quelque chose à vous mais quand
vous voulez voilà je veux montrer une
autre carte bancaire le si est amusante
aussi de la même couleur mais lui autre
chose car des alcooliques anonymes
ah bah oui confrérie des cons mieux vaut
être super con que rien du tout je
dirais tombant charles elachi majine que
vous êtes beaucoup non on n'est pas
nombreux nommé gaye il ya marcel jullian
il ya jean reno et à mesaïeed mais on
n'est pas nombreux ils reprennent on n'a
pas une chance qu'on n'ait pas eu une
centaine a écrit charles aznavour
l'arménien c'est que ces nuits
le music voilà et là avec la carte de
bons clients tout le monde en parle vous
êtes reçu partout dans le monde entier
ah c'est vous monsieur aznavour